benoît d'abord alain chabat est un génie
au trait à naître un génie des d2 il ya
30 ans quand on agit c'est pour la vie
un drap bien sûr toi tu en s'éjectant
sera jamais rien et anvers alors gilles
est un génie jc l'état jouit la dagemo
dijonnais a tout le temps chez gifi une
fois je lui dois la vérité aussi c'est
une sortie dite cercles très très bien
produite ils ont une batterie d'auteurs
aussi gigantesque donc ça aide aussi ce
qui nous a vraiment donné les moyens de
faire l'émission est petit scoop médiane
je sais pour vous binkad othmani mûrir
avant la pub il fera qu alain chabat
aimerait que je sois candidat voir s'il
faut savoir si j'étais alors en face à
la crise
bourgoin oui alors qu'est qui veux juste
leur âge et rui j'étais un petit bémol
on s'est fait la réflexion ce matin
quand on apprend à parler avec celle
qu'il ya on peut voir un peu les
audiences sur les fameuses box et c'est
vrai qu'on pensait que le score serait
beaucoup plus faible
il semblerait quand même que gilles
n'est pas complètement tort sur un point
c'est peu plus de soin à ses plutôt âgée
que de tous les publics sont les
bienvenus est ce qui explique parfois
une seulement isabelle j'étais pas
clientes du tout du burger quiz
autrefois c'est très malin d'avoir fait
revenir chabat effectivement c'est
exactement ce que dieu garde se joue à
la façon la nostalgie est sûre chabat
mais je pense qu'effectivement avec des
jeunes comme toulon est dit en revanche
je ne verrai pas dire beaucoup de gens
france télévisions parce que ils ont
très peu apprécié que si j'ai bien tout
suivi que définie mesure qu'ils soient
liés à des cherry est ce que si on
enlève alain chabat est ce que ça va
compliquer au futur alors sans hélice
alors ça va tout m'a dit c'est bien sûr
pas par 2 par 3 en a qu'un qui pourrait
le remplacer on na vi et laurent baffie
ouais mais laurent baffie les sur s'est
vite oui et non tu sûr
[Rires]